MANISH BHARGAVA: Android
apps today present
a massive opportunity
for developers.
And with the mobile market
emerging as a global force,
to really make an impact you
have to think and act globally.
Worldwide, 1 billion Android
devices have been activated.
With more than 1 million apps in
Play Store, and 50 billion apps
downloaded in over
190 countries,
this is huge opportunity.
My name is Manish.
I'm from Google
Internationalization Team,
and I want to show you
how to crack the code
to engage with the
next 5 billion users.
Let's look at where these
users are coming from.
If you're developing
for and targeting
to only one region,
or a country,
you're only getting
a piece of the pie.
In particular,
with North America,
you're only getting 11%
of the internet users.
Similarly, supporting only
one language in your app
gives you a fraction
of the users.
For example,
supporting only English
gives you 1/4 of the chunk.
You are missing out on
75% of potential users.
Now let's look at where these
future users are coming from.
Let's focus on year over
year growth numbers.
We observe double-digit
growth for emerging markets.
26% in India.
58% for Indonesia.
Compare that to 3%
in the United States.
Now let's look at the
population penetration numbers.
India at 11%.
Indonesia at 23%.
US at 78%.
So the growth numbers for
emerging markets are strong.
But what is even more striking
is that the room to grow
is huge.
Now let's look at the
revenue opportunity.
In Q1 of this year,
Japan overtook the US
as the top country by revenue.
South Korea is a close third.
From revenue growth
perspective, US is not even
in the top five
fastest-growing markets.
South Korea is growing nearly
nine times faster than US.
Japan, with three
times the growth of US,
is set to continue its lead
as a top country for revenue.
Availability of apps in
190 countries is great.
But which market
should I enter first?
What are the key
considerations for you
as you make those decisions?
I'll give you three
key considerations,
which will make your
decision easier.
Different markets behave
differently, with respect
to their app
consumption behavior.
Certain markets are mobile
pioneers-- countries
that are early adopters
of mobile technology.
Notice on the far right
are many large countries,
like Brazil, Russia,
and India, as well as
some smaller but
influential countries,
like Switzerland and Israel.
Besides sharing
similarities in app usage,
these countries
tend to lag behind
in adopting mobile technologies.
Another totally
different consideration
is effort required to
support a group of languages.
You can support Latin
script languages easily,
by doing additional
testing after translation.
CJK-- Chinese, Japanese,
Korean languages--
need attention to font size,
input, and vertical display.
Bi-direction languages,
like Arabic and Hebrew,
are the most challenging.
In these languages, the
text goes right to left;
numbers go left to right.
Special attention is
needed for user interfaces
in these languages.
Third and most
important consideration
is your own app key metrics.
Google Play stats
come in handy here.
Look out for the country
and the language dimensions.
These show you where your
users are coming from,
and which languages
are they using.
This is a strong indicator
of the demand for your app,
and will help you decide
where to localize your app.
Keep your eye on the
localization tips section
in the optimization
tips section.
Here, Google does
the work for you,
and suggests the
market to target,
and languages to localize into.
After looking at
the concentrations,
you have decided on
the markets to enter.
Next, I'll give you a
simple, two-step process
for global success.
First and foremost, localize
your Play Store listing.
Make sure to localize your
app name, your screenshots
and videos, and your
app description.
This will help you go a long way
in your app's global success.
It helps you get higher ranking
and helps you maintain it,
as it reduces the
number of uninstalls.
Finally, this maximizes
your search potential.
This is critical,
as search accounts
for 2/3 of all the installs.
And 50% of the users
search for apps weekly.
Next step is to localize the
experience within your app.
Localization means more
than just translation.
Bring in the cultural aspects of
the country you are targeting.
Your ultimate aim is to make
the users feel that the app has
been created for them,
rather than shipped to them
with some cosmetic changes.
For example, here are the
Hindi and the English versions
of the Zombie Ragdoll app.
Notice that in addition to
translation of the text,
the developer has changed the
rocket propeller to a cricket
ball, changed the
dress of the character
to match the traditional
dress of Indian audience.
When I, as a Hindi-speaking
user from India,
see this in-app experience,
I am more engaged,
as I feel this app has
been created for me.
We just looked at
the steps needed.
Now I will walk you
through how Google
can help you achieve
this global reach.
In Google I/O 2013 keynote,
we announced the availability
of App Translation Service.
You can now simply go to Play
Dev console, click on the APK
section to find the service.
With one button click,
the translation service
is available to you.
You can now follow three simple
key steps for app localization.
These are-- upload your strings
file, select the languages,
choose the vendor
from the marketplace.
With this, you get high-quality,
human translation of your APK,
and you can make it live
right from the Dev console.
The service was made
available to all developers
in November 2013.
In the last six
months, we have seen
200 million installs of the
apps localized by the service.
Using this service makes the
process easier, cost-effective,
and the turnaround time
reduces significantly,
from weeks to days.
For Indian Rummy app, one of the
early adopters of the service.
Besides translation,
internationalization
is an integral part
of going global.
Check out our related
Google I/O doc
on how to get your
app ready to play.
If you have not embarked on
your journey of going global,
now is the perfect
time to do it.
Google is here to assist you.
Go global with Google.